-Performing "Only a Lifetime"
from his new album, "Optimist,"
once again, Finneas.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ How do you know ♪
♪ If you've done
everything right? ♪
♪ Is it the love you have
at hand ♪
♪ Or the cash
you kiss good night? ♪
♪ How do you know ♪
♪ If it was worth it
in the end? ♪
♪ Did every second
really count? ♪
♪ Or were there some
you shouldn't spent? ♪
♪ On anything
but anyone you love ♪
♪ Was this the life
that you were dreaming of? ♪
♪ A movie night,
a yellow light ♪
♪ You're slowing down,
and days are adding up ♪
♪ So don't waste the time
you have ♪
♪ Waiting for time to pass ♪
♪ It's only a lifetime,
that's only a while ♪
♪ It's not worth the anger
you felt as a child ♪
♪ Don't waste the time
you have ♪
♪ Waiting for time to pass ♪
♪ It's only a lifetime,
that's not long enough ♪
♪ You're not gonna like it
without any love ♪
♪ So don't waste it ♪
♪♪
♪ I'm unimpressed ♪
♪ By the people preaching pain ♪
♪ For the sake of
some small gain ♪
♪ In the sake of
someone's name ♪
♪ I'm unprepared ♪
♪ For my loved ones to be gone ♪
♪ Call 'em way too often now ♪
♪ Worry way too much about mom ♪
♪ Don't waste the time
you have ♪
♪ Waiting for time to pass ♪
♪ It's only a lifetime,
that's only a while ♪
♪ It's not worth the anger
you felt as a child ♪
♪ Don't waste the time
you have ♪
♪ Waiting for time to pass ♪
♪ It's only a lifetime,
that's not long enough ♪
♪ You're not gonna like it
without any love ♪
♪ So don't waste it ♪
♪♪
♪ It's family and friends,
and that's the truth ♪
♪ The fountain doesn't
give you back your youth ♪
♪ It's staying up
too late at night ♪
♪ And laughing under
kitchen lights ♪
♪ So hard you start to cry ♪
♪ Don't waste the time
you have ♪
♪ Waiting for time to pass ♪
♪ It's only a lifetime,
that's not long enough ♪
♪ You're not gonna like it
without any love ♪
♪ So don't waste it ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]